[Music]
it was july of 2004 and bill murray was
enjoying the peak of an extremely
successful career
not only had the iconic actors starred
in some of the most beloved comedies of
the 20th century
including ghostbusters and groundhog day
he'd voiced the main character of the
recently released live-action garfield
movie
it'd been a financial success but it was
a critical flop
not that this bothered bill he was happy
with the performance
and the paycheck what he wouldn't be
quite as happy about
was the horrifying encounter he was
about to have with
scp-3166
on july 8th bill was enjoying a cold
drink on the porch of his luxurious
beverly hills home
the sky was beginning to darken as the
sun set in the west
it was a blissful evening his wife
jennifer was inside
watching tv nothing seemed particularly
out of the ordinary
until he noticed a quick flash of orange
in the distance
it was almost too fast to register this
large orange shape darting past the
corner of his eye
for a second he entertained the thought
that it might have been an escaped tiger
but it was gone too fast to really tell
bill finished his drink and headed
inside
he had enough for one night the next
morning he got up to read the paper
and found the garfield movie getting
slaughtered by the critics
one review stated no one can accuse
garfield the movie of infidelity to its
source
it faithfully conveys the banality of
jim davis's cartoon
another called it a film without energy
and without spirit
he put the paper down and ate his
breakfast a few blows to the ego were
worth it for the paydays that came with
big budget family films
just then his wife came to him with a
strange question
were you walking around downstairs in
the middle of the night
no he hadn't he'd been sleeping like a
baby
why did she ask well jennifer said
i heard some rustling downstairs last
night it sounded like something big
he hadn't heard anything though and told
her it was probably just her imagination
he put it out of his mind and continued
about his day he decided he would keep
his eyes peeled for that orange blur
again though
bill didn't see anything peculiar the
rest of the morning and went to a local
cafe for lunch
he ordered a coffee and a cream cheese
bagel then made a quick trip to the
bathroom while his food was prepared
when bill returned to his table though
there was something strange
instead of a bagel there was a large
heaping of lasagna on the table
what was going on this cafe didn't even
serve lasagna
bill knew something was terribly wrong
things only got stranger when bill came
home to find a small
tuft of orange fur snagged on the frame
of his front door
and it wasn't synthetic fur like you'd
see on plush toys or stuffed animals
no this was real animal fur
maybe someone was just goofing off or
trying to play some weird prank on him
but it didn't feel like it deep down
bill murray knew that he was in grave
danger
whoever or whatever was behind this
it wanted to hurt him that night his
worst fears were realized
bill's wife had left town for the week
and he was headed to the kitchen in the
middle of the night for a glass of water
when he saw something a huge figure
moving up against the glass door leading
to his backyard
the thing was huge nearly seven feet
tall
with a bloated fur covered misshapen
body that was pressed up against the
door
its fur was bright garish orange a
cartoon
orange the strangest of all though was
the sound it was making
it sounded like it was purring bill
backed away from the door and then ran
back to his room to hide the whole night
he sat cowering as he heard scratching
against the walls
like something was trying to get in he
was terrified and too scared to do
anything
even move finally as morning bro the
noises seemed to stop
bill had to do something he couldn't let
this nightmare go on another
night what if things got worse what if
that thing
managed to get inside he called the
local police and when they arrived
he explained the incredibly strange
situation as best he could
he told them he was being stalked by
some kind of huge cat
or at least someone dressed like a huge
cat also there was lasagna involved
the officers interviewing him could
barely contain their laughter as he told
them his story
a giant orange cat perhaps one of them
theorized
he angered some kind of obsessive
garfield fan through his involvement in
the live-action movie
after all the original comic had been
running for years
and had been extremely popular who knows
what kind of nut jobs were obsessed with
seeing only a faithful adaptation of the
source material
as the officers departed bill was
confident that they weren't taking him
seriously
he couldn't rely on any of them for
protection thankfully from a
multi-decade movie career
he had plenty of disposable income and
decided to hire a private security team
to protect him
while he looked into this mystery he had
two trained bodyguards positioned around
his home at all times for the next month
they were armed and given the cryptic
orders to fire on
anything orange meanwhile bill began to
fall down a garfield rabbit hole
he felt strangely compelled to research
all the garfield media he could find
as though the answer to his terrifying
situation was somehow hidden between the
lines bill explored the entire backlog
of thousands of comic strips
he read the books and interviews with
jim davis he watched the cartoons and
straight to dvd animated movies
ironically for a guy who'd recently
portrayed the lasagna loving orange cat
bill had never felt quite so immersed in
the character before
he found the strange pathos in the
routine of garfield and his friends
one particular comic really piqued his
interest though
originally published in october of 1989
the comic began with garfield being
woken up by a strange chill
an almost eerie sensation the character
observed aloud that he didn't feel like
he was in his own home
he explored his little home further
trying to find his owner john or his
housemate and sometimes nemesis odie
but found nothing as garfield remarked
on feeling alone
a purple speech box delivered the
sinister message
you have no idea how alone you are
garfield he then finds that his home
looks like it's been abandoned for years
the for sale sign outside is practically
ancient
garfield slowly comes to a horrifying
revelation
everyone really is gone and his
adventures and friends now exist
only in his imagination he's trapped in
a prison of his own creation
trying to stave off his endless
loneliness in denial about the reality
of his situation
the comic ended with a quote directly
from jim davis himself saying
an imagination is a powerful tool it can
tint memories of the past
shade perceptions of the present or
paint a future so
vivid that it can entice or terrify
all depending upon how we conduct
ourselves today
as he read those words bill murray felt
a chill down his spine
why had he wanted to get involved in the
garfield movie in the first place
what had he gotten himself into before
he could slip any deeper into his own
mind
bill heard a faint choked scream
downstairs
he felt his breath catch in his throat
he was terrified
but needed to see what was happening he
carefully
and quietly began to creep down the
stairs at the bottom
he poked his head around a corner and
that's when he saw a member of his
security detail lying dead on the floor
his face was blue from asphyxiation his
mouth was stuffed with lasagna
it looked like he had been force-fed to
death
bill wanted to scream but he couldn't or
maybe knew
he shouldn't just then he heard a soft
meaty thumping noise coming from the
nearby living room
he didn't know why but he felt compelled
to approach
as if by forces beyond his control he
made his way to the living room
and when he'd got there he saw where the
noise was coming from
bill's jaw dropped in pure horror there
was the other member of his security
detail
lying limp and lifeless under a giant
orange figure
who was a grotesquely huge creature
wearing what looked to be a kind of
crude garfield outfit
made of sewn together cat pelts its
stank of pasta and rotten meat
in its giant paw it held a golden trophy
which it was using to pound the security
guard's head into mush
while making quiet cat-like purring
noises
the creature suddenly stopped and looked
up locking eyes with bill
the fear of death came over him he froze
as the giant freakish garfield stepped
over donny's corpse
and began to come towards him bill
turned and ran but garfield was gaining
on him
before he could make it to the front
door the creature knocked him over
he was laid out on the ground looking up
at it as it reached into its own body
cavity and began to pull out handfuls of
lasagna
he was about to shove a wad of the
horrible decaying pasta into bill's
mouth when suddenly a ding was heard
and the creature stopped it looked up as
if sniffing the air
and then suddenly turned and lumbered
towards the kitchen
watched as the garfield monster entered
the kitchen where somehow
there was a steaming hot fresh lasagna
sitting in the open oven
the creature had sensed the presence of
external lasagna
and felt the compulsion to integrate it
into its body
grabbing fistfuls and shoving it into
itself
just then a group of highly trained scp
foundation personnel burst into the room
and subdued the creature
it had been an ambush the foundation had
been tipped off to the presence of the
creature by monitoring the local police
department dispatches
and the report of a seven foot tall
comic book cat terrorizing a hollywood
actor
was definitely worth looking into the
monster that had almost taken bill
murray's life was scp-3160
a deadly pataphysical being that tends
to manifest around people somehow
involved in the garfield intellectual
property
it appears whenever the public
perception of garfield falls out of
favor
and because bill had starred in the
critically panned garfield movie
he was currently at the very top of
scp-3166's hit list
thankfully he managed to survive his
terrifying ordeal
and was administered amnestics by
foundation personnel so that he could
return to his normal life
this frightening and mysterious creature
has been around since 1989
appearing after the publication of the
haunting garfield comic that bill had
read that very night
it appeared in the office of united
media who were the publishers of the
garfield comic strip at the time
and began wrecking havoc since then the
creature's manifestation has been a
constant threat whenever garfield loses
its popularity or audience
as a result the foundation has spent
years as the funding source behind
all garfield media and even planting
hypnotic mimetics into the comic strips
to ensure that there is
always a loyal fan base the fur
is indeed real organic cat fur albeit an
unnaturally orange color
and instead of organs the creature is
filled with lasagna
worst of all though is that testing has
revealed that the meat in the lasagna is
genetically identical to the flesh of
garfield's creator jim davis
how did this thing come into existence
perhaps it was jim's sheer force of
imagination that dragged it into being
as he himself said an imagination is a
powerful
tool all in all it's lucky that bill
murray was able to survive his encounter
and return to his normal life well as
normal as life can be
for bill murray and if you see bill
murray don't bother asking him about
scp-3166
the amnestics were quite effective and
just as he's fond of saying himself
no one will ever believe you now go
check out
scp-5000 the sioux and scp-049 the
plague doctor escapes for more freaky
and fascinating files from your favorite
foundation